hi i'm kristen goodwin on this episode
of the fox news rundown
president biden delivering his first
primetime address to the nation
discussing ongoing efforts to defeat the
coronavirus and the vaccine rollout
which seems to be picking up speed
thanks in part to federally supported
mass vaccination centers
mike sprayberry the executive director
for north carolina's division of
emergency management
who runs a vaccine site in greensboro
details how officials plan to vaccinate
thousands a day and why he's hopeful
about an end to the pandemic
president biden signing the 1.9 trillion
dollar economic relief package into law
clearing the way for another round of
stimulus checks and aid to americans and
businesses
gop senator tim scott of south carolina
discusses why he opposed the relief bill
controversy surrounding his recent
remarks and shares his thoughts on
cancel culture
plus commentary from fox nation host
tammy bruce
the fox news rundown is a daily news
podcast where we
take a deeper look at the stories
important to you you can subscribe on
your favorite podcast player
by going to foxnewspodcast.com i'm jason
chaffetz
i'm katie pavlich i'm steve ducey and
this is the fox news rundown
friday march 12 2021 i'm jessica
rosenthal
it's been one year since the virus
spread was officially declared a global
pandemic
and as difficult as it's been millions
of americans
are now vaccinated what we are hoping is
that these vaccines are going to start
making
a difference i'm chris foster the
democrats coronavirus spending bill is
popular among most americans even a lot
of republicans
but south carolina senate republican tim
scott says he thinks the democrats plans
will backfire
the agenda of the left is so radical
that the center-right country that we
still have is going to have an allergic
reaction
to the medicine brought to the table and
that may be
very good for us in 2022 and prayerfully
in 2024
and i'm tammy bruce i've got the final
word on the fox news rundown
[Music]
it's been one year since the spread of
covet 19 was declared a pandemic by the
world health organization
a couple of days later president trump
declared a national emergency
and as the white house pushed 15 days to
slow the spread
many of us did not anticipate the year
it would end up being
the run on toilet paper the lockdowns
the loss of jobs and permanent closing
of restaurants
for many loneliness for others fear of
the virus
but during this past year the light at
the end of the tunnel remained
vaccines when i came into office you may
recall
i set a goal that many of you said was a
kind of way over the top
i said i intended to get a hundred
million shots in people's arms in my
first 100 days in office
tonight i can say we're not only going
to meet that goal
we're going to beat that goal in his
first televised address to the nation
thursday night president biden
commemorated the year it's been
and the lives we've lost to covet 19. as
i've told you before
i carry a card in my pocket but the
number of americans
who have died from covert to date it's
on the back of my schedule
as of now total deaths in america
527 thousand
seven hundred and twenty six nearly five
hundred twenty eight
thousand people he directed states to
make all adults eligible for vaccines
starting may first
and said they would launch new tools
including a website
to make it easier to find out where to
get a vaccine
we do this together by july the 4th
there's a good chance you
your families and friends will be able
to get together in your backyard or in
your neighborhood
and have a cookout on a barbecue and
celebrate independence day
now to get to this point the federal
government has had a very hands-on role
with the pharmaceutical companies that
have created the vaccines
providing money and coordination buying
millions of vaccines and working to ship
them to state and local officials
pharmacies and to fema supported
vaccination sites
like one in greensboro north carolina
where i and other reporters got a tour
this week ahead of the opening these are
called pods
and that's where people will come in
really it's a full service operation not
only will they get their
vaccine administered there they'll also
stay there for observation
correct inside the four seasons town
center mall in an empty dillards
location
chairs are spaced out for people to sit
in while receiving the vaccine
and behind them is a small room so our
air force team will be working from this
area here
as you can see they have various
workstations
set up to properly mix the vaccine
along with drawing the doses up mandy
williford the emergency planning
pharmacist with north carolina state
public health
also showed us where the vials of pfizer
vaccine were being kept
in freezers at minus 71 degrees celsius
they expect to administer 3000 vaccines
a day at this location for the next
eight weeks in the city of greensboro
which was selected as
one of the federal vaccination sites our
fema partners
using what they call the social
vulnerability
index mike sprayberry is the director of
north carolina emergency management
actually guides us towards making
decisions on
where we find what are characterized as
historically marginalized populations
people of color
also people that are you know have you
know socioeconomic
issues and so that guides us in that
direction
so that we know that those are that's a
population that we need to be working
you know doubly hard to serve
we need to make sure that they're not
forgotten and so
um fema said listen based on the sbi
we think greensboro would be a good
location and so
we had thought maybe some other cities
might be as well but
greensboro turned out to be the one and
so we looked at a couple of
other locations here and um
obviously the acc tournament had
something to do
with us not work going over there but
this worked out pretty good and so
since the federal government is uh
basically paying the freight
for this operation hard to turn down
168 000 doses that doesn't go against
the state's allocation
right so that's above and beyond our
allocation and right now
um vaccine is still not at the supply
level that we want it at
um although you we can see it you're
like me
you see it every day the announcement
the news
it's growing incrementally the amount of
vaccines but the faster that we can get
people vaccinated
the better it is so good deal tell me a
little bit about
how this works logistically because when
greensboro was first announced as the
site it was only one of two sites that
was announced that the
the federal government was um operating
and now
it sounds like we've heard that there
are many more sites like that around the
country am i am i right
i wouldn't i wouldn't say many more i
would say some more and so
what i did is when i talked with
regional administrator check
you know we saw where california
and florida we're getting
these pilot community vaccination
centers
and so um the discussion that i had with
her
i told her i said well you know
california
they have 40 million people um you know
florida's got
19 to 20 million you know north carolina
is
number nine in the nation with 10 and a
half million
so you know i suggest to her that it
wouldn't be long
that you know we would probably be on
deck
for getting one of these sites and so
we both agreed that was probably the way
it was going to happen
and in fact that is what happened and so
so we're seeing you know states like
illinois ohio
georgia north carolina you know the top
10 states get them
i i think that they'll probably be more
but i'm not the decider talk to me about
costs
to run this i mean who's funding this
my understanding is the federal
government isn't funding all of it i
mean
you said earlier that some of this is
going to be reimbursed but
how much of it so you know all of our
um eligible costs will be reimbursed and
so
that's a typical statement that you hear
from
really any grant program and this is a
public assistance grant program
emergency protective measures category b
and so we have that
you know what will happen is we do what
project worksheets
and so we will invoice
the federal government some of our big
costs
like the mall in this parking lot free
because because the four seasons town
center here is is donating it right they
donated right
so that was a good lick for us um so
then you have um
you know the dod
dod they're on title 10 orders they're
already on active duty
so we don't have to pay anything there
we don't have to request any
reimbursement
meals and lodging we have to re you know
we pay
we submit that for repayment i.t
infrastructure
ipads stuff like that that we'll be
using
you know we'll get reimbursed for that
jessica i will tell you that you know
in any disaster event emergency event
fema has these uh you know projects and
we execute the projects and so
like in a hurricane we will spend a ton
of money on
national guard and then we'll package it
up and we'll send it to
the feds fema and then they will
reimburse us
tell me finally sir as the director of
north carolina emergency management
um how has the past year been for you
because you're used to i'm from
california we're used to dealing with
wildfires we have command centers set up
for wildfires and earthquakes
you guys all have hurricanes here um
every state every region has
their emergency response that they're
used to dealing with but i don't think
anybody
has set up you know the command centers
and the logistics and all that for a
pandemic
and i'm wondering just from an emergency
management perspective
given your prior experience with other
issues with other
problems how has this past year been so
we did have a taste of it with h1n1 in
2009 in dealing with
prophylaxis and medical warehouses
and i think also one of the things that
we learned
from that event and plus uh just
basically working closely with our state
emergency response team partners
is that i
stay in close contact with my teammates
even like on days like today so we have
um meetings with the chief
epidemiologist from dhhs
to talk about communicable diseases
that's not during pandemics that's just
during normal times
and so you know that's what we do
and so we i've got a bio surveillance
email that comes to me every day from
and it's tracking diseases all over the
world
like ebola the african swine fever
all that stuff and so we talked with the
those folks and actually you know we
were tracking
on this a little bit before it actually
happened
i mean we we knew it was happening over
in china but uh
i mean we didn't i don't think we
clearly anticipated
you know how it would really blow up
right
we knew about it um and so
my big lesson learned was you know
we'll continue working closely with dhhs
keep those relationships strong but also
we learned about um ppe right
and so we had some i mean
and i don't think we could ever have
enough to outfit the whole state
but we certainly need to have enough to
sort of hold the line
um until the feds get here with their
sns
we have a state strategic stockpile now
but we want to make sure that we're
always ready
we want to make sure we continue to
communicate with our
dhhs folks but what we are hoping
in this 365th day of the activation of
the stadio c
for the pandemic is that these vaccines
are going to start making
a difference and so that we're going to
turn the corner
my last question for you let's see you
have to go is um
when we were going through the walk
through earlier you were talking
about emotionally how this makes you
feel um
how how does this make you feel that
you're about to start vaccinating
thousands of people
and you you set this up well
are you kidding this is the greatest
feeling ever and so
you know i'm just old guy from west
charlotte and um
you know to know that i'm working with
these professional
teammates that i have that are just so
talented
and that we're gonna be able to help
people
potentially we're gonna we know we're
gonna save some lives
and keep people from getting sick i mean
that's the best feeling ever right best
ever
director spray berry thank you so much
for your time thank you
this is tammy bruce with your fox news
commentary coming up
the democrats coronal virus financial
relief and stimulus plan is signed into
law by president biden this historic
legislation
is about rebuilding the backbone of this
country and giving people in this nation
working people
middle class folks people who built the
country
of fighting chance the nearly two
trillion dollar american rescue plan
passed with precisely
zero republican support in the house or
the senate they'd presented a plan at
the white house the president found to
be too small
so democrats would their new majorities
in the house and senate go it alone
passing the first bill of the biden
presidency well what they really wanted
was to find a way to
usher in their liberal progressive pay
everybody bill
tim scott's a republican senator from
south carolina we spoke to him yesterday
and unfortunately they were able to
succeed at that but
hopefully we'll have a chance to push
back on it it is
one of the most ridiculous pieces of
legislation that had
so little to do with covet relief and
everything to do with a progressives
wish list
i mean you can have these calls for
bipartisanship but in the end they
really they just needed
joe manchin and other centrist democrats
right
absolutely when you look at what they've
done they were able to to
i don't know when these were buy off but
they were able to negotiate with mansion
to lower the unemployment from 400 to
300 but then they extended it to
september said
in a different way i believe what we
said what we saw happened there
was they are now paying people to stay
home
even longer not through june or july but
now through september
and interestingly enough chris the
unemployment rate has gone down
not up we have 379 000 new jobs added to
the economy
the last thing we need to do is extend
the unemployment benefits
until september when in fact the
recovery as fragile as it is
continues senator a lot of americans
are very happy about are going to be
very happy about this bill including
some of your constituents south
carolina's got something like the 10th
highest poverty rate in the country and
a lot of people
are going to be very happy to get this
child tax credit and getting essentially
huge raises in their take-home pay what
do you tell them
well chris this is this is an easy one
honestly the road to socialism starts
with one step
and the bottom line is that what we're
looking at here is not
paying people for increased production
not paying people for
increased uh challenges that were
brought on by the government they're
simply
making this into the progressives
approach
to ushering in the first few steps of
socialism
and that is a huge challenge a new study
shows that
all the covet stimulus costs each
american
17 000 that that means that we are
simply pushing ourselves in the wrong
direction with these resources being put
out there
but yes people like money there's no
question about that but when they
understand that they
have to pay it back they like it less
and when you add interest on top of that
they like it even less
and when they understand that they may
be compromising the future
of the next generation of americans by
spending money today that we don't have
that we have to borrow from china that's
a bad thing for every single american
and every single american child
that we have the generations to come
will face
an avalanche of debt unnecessarily
so because of two trillion dollars under
the guise of cobit relief
when in fact it's social policy
that transforms the american economy
yeah now this i mean look this only got
through because of budget reconciliation
where spending bills
could be passed with 50 votes and no
filibustering now other than spending
bills
are democrat is this a last gasp for
them
are they going to get anything through
their voting rights bill the house
passed last week
an infrastructure plan there's gun
legislation pending and if they can't if
they can't get any gop
votes on anything might they just throw
their hands up and say fine we're
killing the filibuster everything needs
50 votes
well you know we i watched joe manchin
uh try to walk through that
minefield on sunday and the truth of the
matter is what he said was
that he is willing to make the
filibuster harder to use
that is very dangerous the filler buster
conversation
is a slippery slope we know that if you
give the democrats an inch they want a
mile
and that's not good for the american
people and frankly the agenda of the
left
is so radical that the center-right
country that we still have
is going to have an allergic reaction
to the medicine brought to the table and
that may be
very good for us in 2022 and prayerfully
in 2024
but more importantly it is just bad
policy and the stench of
it will i think make people nauseous
uh the more we see listen the the
thought that we're going to give a 16
year old
the right to vote because they believe
they do better with younger people than
we
do doesn't sound like they're looking
for a way to level the playing field the
thought that they want to
nationalize elections we should be
looking for ways to
limit male imbalance not expand mail-in
ballots we should be looking for ways to
expand
voter id not eliminate voter id so
what they're trying to do is position
this country
not to recover from their lurch
and then leak to the far far far left
those are dangerous positions in their
hr1
and you and i both know that we are
going to have to fight truth and male to
protect the second amendment
we are in for that fight we are in it to
win it we will
because america was founded on the
concept that we must be
we must have the resources and the arms
necessary to defend ourselves
period and that must stand and that is
one of the things that's one of the
reasons why we should be very thankful
for our constitution and especially our
second amendment rights
how about immigration any common ground
there we're seeing the surge especially
of kids coming in maybe emboldened by
the president having said people asking
for refugee status aren't going to be
automatically kept in mexico just you
know more lenient
overall do you see some common ground
there where we can have border security
and allow more people illegally with the
past citizenship maybe
well i certainly hope that we find a way
to create the meritocracy
that is in the best interest of our
nation the front door is incredibly
important
we should open that front door to those
folks that improve the quality of life
experienced by everyday americans we
need to not always
shut the back door we need to lock the
back door
think about this if nancy pelosi is
willing to build a fence around the
capitol
why won't she build a border that is
secure
it doesn't make any sense to me if you
believe in security for yourself
why can't you believe in security for
all americans and
closing and locking the back door is in
fact
common sense for the safety and the
security
of this nation i'm happy to have a
negotiation on the front door i'm happy
to have a negotiation
about a merit-based system that provides
us with the workers we need
and that continues to do what we've done
for the last 245 years
be a home for folks who are looking to
improve our country
not tear it apart senator scott's the
only black republican in the senate
and last week msnbc host joy reid also
black
said his presence gives the party the
patina of diversity
monday on fox news channel senator scott
told host trey gowdy on fox news
primetime
woke supremacy is as bad as white
supremacy
we need to take that seriously that set
off cnn host don lemon also
african-american saying on his show
wednesday
i've never seen a woke supremacist
lynching anybody never saw woke
supremacists
denying anybody access to housing
or job or education or voting rights
never saw any woke supremacist enslaving
anybody
never saw any woke supremacist trying to
keep people from
marrying amongst different races
come on tim scott so we asked the
senator if you'd like to clarify or
expand on what he meant
absolutely what number one what i said
was that
woke supremacy can be as dangerous at
least that's what i
attempted to say as white supremacy and
the reason why i said that was
there is a person today on trial who has
pled guilty
to wanting to take me out and that
person will be
sentenced on i think march the 29th of
this month
he's a african-american liberal who
believes that i am out of place
but i don't know my place that his brand
of wokeness
is so extreme that he's willing to
imperil my life
so when i talked about that i was of
course using a little hyperbole there's
no question that
the history of our country and the
history of white supremacy
is one that includes death and murder
and the worst
of what we would like to see the history
of our country
is that we continue to move our arts
then towards justice even though it has
been
uh littered with people who wanted to
take advantage of other people
that that is bad but just as
bad maybe not as extreme but just as bad
is this theory of bulk supremacy where
in fact
people who look like me or young white
liberals believe that they can now say
if you're not one of us
we cancel you if you're not staying in
line
you don't exist if you are not
in line with a liberal philosophy then
you are in fact
an american you are in fact not black
you are in fact not female you're not
you're in fact
not hispanic what i'm talking to is that
underlying
philosophy that is antithetical to what
it means to be american
and our history proves that
while we have had our challenges and i
have lived through some of those
challenges personally of racism
the truth is we continue generation
upon generation to get better and better
and better
we are living in my opinion in the
fairest
america in the fairest country ever
woven together
because of that i want to sound the
alarm
against those who feel like they are in
power today
to bring their brand of extremism and
supremacy
to the surface and punish others who are
not like them
having been discriminated against the
last thing i would want to do
is discriminate against others well look
thanks for that and i'm sure it's not
necessarily fair that you get dragged
into discussions about
your race in addition to just talking
about policy i'm not asking kevin
mccarthy about being white you know i
mean i guess it's just the cost of doing
business in your position
well it is and hey thank you chris for
giving me an
opportunity to to actually talk
through what it was that i meant tv is
such a short venue
you've given me an opportunity to really
flesh out
not the equivocation between two extreme
positions
but to understand why we should be very
leery of a new generation of folks who
believe
that one is better than the other it was
bad in the past it's bad
in the present it will be bad in the
future no matter the color of your skin
south carolina senator tim scott on the
rundown senator thanks a lot for talking
to us
thank you chris have a great day
[Music]
fox news radio on demand on the fox news
app download the app
and just click listen when you swipe
left you can listen to your favorite fox
news talk shows
live swipe right for the latest fox news
radio newscasts on demand fox news radio
and the fox news app
download it today read and review the
fox news rundown on apple podcasts or
wherever you listen
and now some good news with tanya j
powers
a minnesota priest has chosen something
pretty substantial to give up for lent
this year father john eubal says during
this season of sacrifice he's giving up
his collection of baseball cards
something he's amassed over almost five
decades
that's the thing about collecting it
brings you back to a point in time
his collection includes a 1948 jackie
robinson rookie card and
another of hank aaron father eubal is
donating it to the aim hire foundation
in minnesota for private school
scholarships
for families in financial need our
schools are doing a great job
i have all these cards i hardly look at
them
and so i called up a couple of people at
aim higher foundation said i've got an
idea hear me out
aim higher vice president ricky austin
says they did
we listened to father eubal's pitch and
immediately we were all in
to provide this creative way
to give back to the community making
sure that doesn't matter the size of a
parent's paycheck
that they can get into the schools that
best serve their children the collection
almost didn't make it to 2021. father
eubal says when he was switching work
assignments in 2003 he
almost got rid of the cards i literally
had all the cards in a girl scout cookie
box where they've been stored
i just was going to throw away cards to
free up more space
he says he was at a dumpster ready to
toss them when he decided at the last
minute
to keep them and i can tell you i've
never been happier
to give something away in my life than
this this has been so fun i'm having a
time of my life
father eubal says he's hoping to raise
between 25 and 30 thousand dollars for
the aim hire foundation event to find
out more go to the aim hire foundation
dot org
tanya j powers fox news
[Music]
it's time for your fox news commentary
tammy bruce
bruce what's on your mind one of the
main concerns when joe biden was elected
president was that he was going to open
the southern border
there was good reason to worry about
that considering the obama biden
disastrous immigration policies
but this time was different we heard
some people say there's no way the biden
administration would dare to reverse
former president trump's success
at controlling the border because hey
we're fighting off a pandemic
the last thing anyone would do would be
to open the southern border that's just
crazy talk
well apparently not so crazy because
that's exactly what's happening
the trump immigration and border
policies could not have come at a better
time
considering the arrival of the china
virus prior to this deadly viral
pandemic delivered up by china
trump policies were mitigating the
steady stream of disease and viruses
brought into this country
by immigrants trying to cross the border
in 2019 reuters reported
when undocumented immigrants were found
at the border to be infected with
everything ranging from mumps
tuberculosis chickenpox and influenza
among other contagions
they were quarantined and often removed
it appears that precaution
has been abandoned along with the biden
administration essentially erasing the
southern border
we have now learned that for the
thousands who are once again rushing
into the country only a few are tested
for covet 19
and for those who test positive we shrug
and they continue their journey
into the interior of our country the
washington examiner tells us
border patrol and ice are not testing
anyone taken into custody
border patrol has been increasingly
releasing people from its custody
because ice does not have room to accept
transfers migrants who are released rely
on greyhound
and other bus companies to travel to
their final destinations
in the united states this catastrophe is
the result of electing a man
who had run for president condemning mr
trump's handling of the coronavirus
and pledging to solve the crisis and
crush the pandemic
instead he has set into motion the
actual importation of people
with the coronavirus who are then
allowed to go on their way with no
controls
and no plan for mitigation the biden
administration has absolutely no plan
and no real interest in securing the
border or in keeping covet 19 from
coming into the country
right now you cannot take a flight into
the united states even if you're a
citizen
without a negative coveted test but you
can walk across the border without any
confirmation of your health status
one of the main methods used by
undocumented migrants to disappear into
our nation is via bus
even people who have tested positive at
the bus terminal in brownsville
are not presented with any direction or
restrictions about their movement
most of those people then board a bus
for in many instances
cross-country trips confined with a
multitude of other people
for hours if not days while politicians
continue to dilly dally
over at independent women's voice of
which i'm president we are acting on a
variety of issues to make a difference
including having a petition for you to
sign demanding that the biden
administration
apply all travel requirements and
coveted screening procedures
to everyone equally and fairly including
those at the border
if you are refused entry to this country
through an airport
unless you can produce a negative covet
19 test at the very least we must have
that same standard at every point of
entry
no matter who is trying to enter the
country this is about keeping you your
family and community safe but it is also
about not abandoning those
to serious and sometimes deadly health
risks who have already risked so much
coming to this country
they then disappear into migrant
communities across the country
subjecting those underserved communities
to even more risk
and devastation
you've been listening to the fox news
rundown stay up to date by subscribing
to this podcast at foxnewspodcasts.com
and for up to the minute news
go to foxnews.com
from the fox news podcasts network
subscribe and listen to the trey gowdy
podcast former federal prosecutor and
four-term u.s congressman from south
carolina brings you a one-of-a-kind
podcast
subscribe and listen now by going to
foxnewspodcasts.com
love fox news click the subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust
and click the fox news rundown playlist
for the latest episodes